الى اخر تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
حيث قالت القوات الجويه الاوكرانيه انها
دمرت 18 مسيره من طراز شاهد كانت متجهه
نحو العاصمه وقالت الاداره العسكريه في
كييفنا سقوط حطام الطائرات المسيره التي
اسقطتها الدفاعات الجويه ادى الى وقوع
اضرار ماديه وحرائق في سيارات ومبان في
اربعه احياء بالعاصمه هذا واوضحت ان هذا
الهجوم يعد الحادي عشر منذ بدايه الشهر
الجاري اكدت ان القوات الروسيه تحاول
جاهده الحاق الضرر بالاماكن الرئيسيه في
العاصمه واستنفاذ موارد الدفاعات الجويه
وابقاء المدنيين في حاله توتر حسب وصفها
[موسيقى]
من جهه اخرى قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه
ان طفلا قتل في قصف روسي استهدف مناطق
كليفري وسافولوجيا وخيرسون جنوبيه البلاد
واوضحت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه القصف خلف
دمارا في المباني عده من جهته قال حاكم
خرسون الاوكرانيين القوه الروسيه قصفت
المقاطعه خلال الساعات الماضيه اكثر من 50
مره واطلقوا ما يزيد على ثلاثمائه قطيفه
استهدفت مناطق ماهوله بالسكان
عمده المقاطعه استمرار القصف الروسي على
طول المناطق الساحليه واسفر عن تدمير
منازل العتاب
مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان اهلا بك
اذا هجمات وانفجارات قويه في اكياف ما اخر
المعلومات لديك
نعم سفيان بالفعل هي الهجمه الحاديه عشر
على التوالي منذ بدايه شهر مايو كما تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه هنا في العاصمه
هذه الهجمات تتنوع في كل يوم بشكلها
بطبيعتها وبتوقيتها وبحجمها اليوم استفقت
هذه العاصمه على هجمه بثماني عشره مسيره
انتحاريه وجهت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه في
عدد من المواقع السلطات الاوكرانيه تقول
ان هذه الهجمات كانت موجهه نحو المراكز
الرئيسيه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه وان
الدفاعات الجويه كما تقول السلطات اسقطت
كافه هذه المسيرات التي كانت تتجه نحو
المدينه ولكن المختلف هذه المره سفيان ان
بعض المسيرات تمكنت من الوصول الى مناطق
حساسه وسط المدينه نحن كنا قد رصدنا خلال
هذه الليله احدى المسيرات الانتحاريه من
طراز شاهد كما تقول السلطات وصلت الى عمق
والى قلب المدينه مدينه كييف وتحديدا الى
ميدان وبالقرب من قصر الرئاسه قبل ان تقوم
الدفاعات الجويه باعتراضها واسقاطها في
السماء وهذا ربما يشير الى ما تحذر منه
السلطات الاوكرانيه من ان الدفاعات الجويه
تستنزف بهذه الهجمات المتكرره والقويه نحو
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كانت هجمات قد شهدتها
العاصمه خلال الايام الماضيه بصواريخ
تتنوع باشكالها وباتجاهاتها من البحر
والجو والبر بشكل متزامن كانت وجهت ضربات
بصواريخ فرد صوتيه من طراز كنجال وصواريخ
من طراز اسكندر وغيرها من طراز كاليبر
التي تطلق من البحر ثم كذلك كان هناك
هجمات بصواريخ كروز موسعه نحو العاصمه
الاوكرانيه واليوم نحن نشهد هذه الهجمه
ايضا الموسعه بالمسيرات وعلى ما يبدو ان
بعض المسيرات تمكنت من الاختراق وهو ما
ربما يشير الى تاثر الدفاعات الجويه خلال
هذه الفتره الاخيره وهو مع تحذر منه
السلطات الاوكرانيه ولكن بكل الاحوال
السلطات الاوكرانيه ما زالت تؤكد ان
الدفاع الجويه اسقطت كافه المسيرات التي
وجهت نحو العاصمه هذه الهجمه ادت الى
اضرار في عدد من المواقع في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف نشاهد هنا هذا الموقع احد
المواقع التي تعرضت
لحطام المسيرات كما تقول السلطات وادت الى
اضرار ببعض المواقع ببعض المناطق وكذلك
ببعض السيارات حرائق ودمار في عده مواقع
اطلعنا عليها خلال هذا اليوم تم التعامل
معها لحتى اللحظه لم يتم الاعلان عن
اصابات بشريه في هذه الهجمات ولكن
القوات الاوكرانيه والسلطات الاوكرانيه
باتت تحذر المواطنين بشكل اكبر من التعامل
مع صفارات الانذار لماذا لان قياس كانت قد
عاشت خلال الفتره الاخيره بعض الايام التي
كانت ربما تشهد هدوءا حذرا في
المنطقه وكانت تشهد
للعيش بشكل شبهي طبيعي كما تقول كما يقول
السكان هنا ولكن العاصمه الان باتت تعيش
حاله اخرى مختلفه عادت مشاهد الدمار مشاهد
الضرر مشاهد القصف هذه المناطق للعاصمه
الاوكرانيه وعادت الحاله التي تشبه الحاله
التي عاشتها العاصمه في بدايات الحرب نظرا
لكثافه الهجمات باتجاه العاصمه كنا ايضا
قد تابعنا كيف اعلنت السلطات عدد من
الاجراءات الاضافيه خلال الايام الماضيه
من بينها
الطلب من الحافلات ومن شركات النقل ان
تنقل المواطنين مباشره نحو الملاجئ في حال
سماع ذوي السفارات الانذار بشكل مجاني
وعدد من الاجراءات التي تشير الى ان
القوات والسلطات الاوكرانيه تخشى ان تكون
هذه الهجمات قد اثرت على دفاعات الجويه
وان تصل الصواريخ او المسيرات خلال الايام
الماضيه الى الاماكن اكثر في العاصمه
الاوكرانيات